il
en termes et si je comprends bien oui
j'ai depuis 16 ans avec roxane c'est à
dire qu'enfin je vous présente pouchkine
en attendant parce que vous avons la
chance d'avoir pouchkine avec nous
voulons vraiment de très brefs instants
parce que c'est quelqu'un de très très
indépendant il n'aime pas être pris sur
les genoux ça c'est un va repartir dans
le jardin dans ses activités mystérieuse
vous la présente
voilà pour ce qu'ils n'étaient là
effectivement je ne vis pas depuis 16
ans avec roczen jeunes à 16 ans c'est
donc une c'est une chienne gwendal c'est
une vieille dame déjà un gain de 16 ans
je crois que même dans cette race là je
ne suis pas un homme très très fort mais
pas de très grande connaissance elle a
les moyens là c'est vous
oui et je crois que les grandes dalles
sont plutôt fragile la presse que m'a
dit le vétérinaire
roxane à 16h moi je vis avec elle depuis
14 ans ça a été la dot de ma femme j'ai
épousé une femme qui avait une fille et
une sienne alors que c'est encore une
soif
ces terres étaient les 2es journées je
suis tout à fait je suis plus que
content plus que ravis l'ouvrier roxane
a bien vécu et bien vieilli à bien me
roxane c'est la sienne aidé à bien
vieilli avec nous quant à la fille et
les temps on a complètement les très
belles je crois qu'elle est très
heureuse et que tout le monde est bien
manceau petit de ceux dans ce modeste
d'arbres et puis il y à bout de skins
aussi puisqu'il est un élément rajouter
beaucoup ce qu'il ne correspond à un
voeu de la fille la fille qui s'appelle
tatiana et tout ce qui ne
été trouvé par tatiana dans un petit
chemin dont seul endroit où habiter et
la virtu quelques fois récompensé
c'était un petit animal sans apparence
un petit animal de quelques ours en
apparence perdu et en vieillissant c'est
devenu un très beau chat angora et
d'aucuns disent même que c'est une
c'est une race asiatique de d'angora non
enfin de toute façon c'est un personnage
boussekine un personnage à la fois
sournois et etsi et sociable c'était
pour moi c'est un service de
renseignement c'est ainsi pour moi c'est
un service de renseignement je sais
toujours à l'avant sont quand ma femme
traverse le pont de sèvres avec sa
voiture
c'est à dire on est à 2 km la bomba je
sais pertinemment par un étirement un
bâillement du chat que oui ça c'est
formidable
et puis il ya quelque chose de
sainte-thérèse beaucoup et tout ce qui
se passe dans le voisinage la chienne
n'est pas jeune bien sûr maintenant un
mois c'est elle qui garde
c'est elle qui garde la maison la sienne
malgré son âge et enfin elle est très
belle vous l'avez vu là encore de grands
succès masculin donc il ya toujours des
fuites il faut encore des moments dit
encore des moments de l'année où elle
est très sollicitée par l'élément mal du
quartier et il ya des bugs qui arrivent
à se débattre
la notion de bêtes à un peu dépassée
chez une fin juillet ne savions rien
oublier de retomber dans
dans le mauvais passé verbal parce que
il ya une assimilation total 2,2 fin de
ce chien est complètement intégré ya pas
de bêtes
d'ailleurs la notion de bête j'ai
l'impression qu'elle a complètement
disparu maintenant quand j'étais gosse
mois la campagne il y avait les chiens
ont disons au fait la soupe aux siens on
se lasse ou projet chasse démerder comme
il voulait pour bouffer et si on leur
refuse plus de soupe à l'eau de
vaisselle tout ça mais il se tait de
cinq vivaient et vivait bien sûr mais
maintenant c'est tout à fait c'est
peut-être un peu parce que je suis
plongé dans la vie dans la vie
parisienne et dans la vie urbaine
bon revenons donc à moumoute à nos
moutons ou plutôt à un autre ça parce
que je suis un peu un roi de la la
parenthèse donc cette sienna encore
maintenant de grands succès le grand
succès masculin et chaque fois que quand
un chien arrive à saint-cloud
s'introduire dans la maison il est
automatiquement ça c'est par le parent
de chat mais ce chat qui n'a l'air de
rien du tout c'est une très très grosse
impression de la pression'' beaucoup les
beaucoup les chiens ils les braves
ainsi là nous avons derrière la haie
nous avons un saut est un voisin c'est
un sochaux très très très mal très et/ou
de screen passe son temps à le braz et
ans
lalande long en large dont le largue ans
et elle argue aussi un chien en face
enfin fait des choses et va rôder autour
de sa niche pendant la nuit
c'est des choses ça que c'est un
personnage très très étonnant quand on
habitait sur l'autre coteaux la roxane
était plus jeune et il avait un tel sens
de leur mauvaise gestion des transports
en commun c'est pratique d'ailleurs
habituellement lieu où il est facile de
prendre des trains il ya intra pour le
sur la river boat intra sur la rive
droite tout ça et il était arrivé à un
tel sens de mes deux meilleurs de
rentrer bien que mes heures de rentrée
soit quelquefois irrégulière mais je ne
sais pas il écouté ce que je disais ils
disaient ils écoutés ils devaient
prendre le train vers telle heure j'y
retrouverai quelquefois près de la gare
tous les deux assis avec devant la gare
en train de m'attendre mais c'est très
très curieux d'ailleurs ces deux bêtes
et qu'il était apparemment pas fait pour
s'entendre parce que rien se dit
toujours des bacs
roxane quand elle avant de connaître son
ca est devenu sans ça elle n'avait pas
de sympathie particulière pour les
autres félins c'est à dire qu'elle est
poursuivie les courses et je croyais
même que c'était une antipathie que
c'était pour leur faire mal et puis
quand tu pousses qui n'était arrivé vous
dans cette maison on a été évidemment
très très prudent et puis on en faire le
push pin dans une pièce et on attendait
que
5e roczen soit sorti pour la faire
ressortir et puis un jour on est avec ma
femme où il est allé dans paris on est
allé dîner chez des amis
on avait mis isolé pouchkine bien sûr et
puis roxane et quand quand on est rentré
au stupeur au terreur la porte était
ouverte
roxane avait ouvert la porte de la
chambre de tatiana où ont été plantés
tout ce qu'ils avaient ouvert la porte
il était couché l'un en face de l'autre
en train de se regarder son avec
l'unique c était ce ce moment
d'observation et le ça pendant une
longue période est devenu le chat du
chien c'est à dire que quand on prenait
on quand on prenait boussekine on l'a
frustré totalement et
sonné elle le couvrait de baisers il
avait une haine
toutes ces maternités refoulé en foule
toujours un peu des maternités les des
animaux parce qu'on nous seraient
encombrés de petits nez de tissus ou
d'un égoïsme pour ça bien sûr en civil
leur sexualité et leur sens de la
maternité est basse et le la et la fumée
les le tour porté à faire porsche le
pouce king qui est un set cette boule de
poils étaient toujours couverte de
salive affectueux de de roxane facettes
un couple et un enfant